bonjour en cette période d'halloween oui
encore je voulais vous parler d'un sujet
cool la sorcellerie en restant dans le
domaine historique bien sûr cependant en
faisant une petite recherche je me suis
dit qu'il serait peut-être judicieux de
commencer par vous présenter
l'inquisition
même si elle ne s'est pas cantonné qu'au
procès de sorcellerie ça reste un sujet
super intéressant alors c'est parti
l'inquisition a dans l'imaginaire
populaire une idée de violence de
justice arbitraire de buch et enflammé
et c'était vrai merci au revoir
ok c'est faux ces idées reçues sont
véhiculés en partie par étienne léon de
lamotte langon qui écrit une histoire de
l'acquisition de france en 1811 basé sur
des archives inédites la 7e va vous
étonner quand un pseudo historien
prétend avoir accès à des archives de
fou que personne n'avait jamais vu avant
souvent ça sent le roussi
dans ce livre il montre les crimes des
inquisiteurs très très méchant en face à
des hérétiques très gentil et c'est de
la connerie
ces archives n'ont jamais existé en fait
etienne faisait partie de la mouvance
anti clérical de l'époque l'église c'est
pourri pourri son l'église on n'est pas
chez hb au l'inquisition pontifical donc
est une institution créée par l'église
sans déconner je ne parlerai pas de
l'inquisition espagnole d'ailleurs parce
que c'est pas tout à fait la même chose
voilà l'inquisition qui nous intéresse
est créée vers 1231 dans le but de
sauver les âmes des chrétiens face aux
crises que l'église traverse dès la fin
du xiième siècle l'église commence à
être critiquée par les populations elles
ne font plus trop confiance aux membres
du clergé
parce que ce sont quand même des gens
normaux à la base beaucoup ont été
mariées avant d'être clair on parle pas
encore bordera par et bref c'est
monsieur tout le monde pourrait vivre du
travail des autres sans que ça choque
personne
et ben si ça choque la littérature
populaire commencent à répandre des
idées de corruption et de cupidité du
clergé
ce qui complique un petit peu le travail
de l'église en plus de ça apparaisse des
mouvements hérétiques
mais où va-t-on on peut distinguer deux
mouvements erratiques qui sont
condamnées par l'église est jugé par les
tribunaux inquisitoriaux les vaudois et
les cathares les vaudois apparaissent
vers 1170 sous l'impulsion de pierre
valdés
originaire de lyon et qui prône le
retour à la pauvreté pour les membres du
clergé
au début ce qu'il fait ne déplaît pas
trop il traduit l'ancien testament
mais finalement il est jugé trop à tort
pour l'église il autorise des femmes a
prêché il n'y a aucune hiérarchie dans
son mouvement une seule messe
obligatoire dans l'année vous venez
comme vous êtes
il est excommunié en 1984 puis tous les
vaudois sont condamnés en 1215 et se
dispersent vers l'est de la france
l'italie et la germanie les cathares se
trouve dans le languedoc del
11e siècle et sont un peu plus extrême
que les vaudois par exemple il rejette
la consommation de chair animale le
mariage ils reconnaissent aux laïcs le
droit de prêcher et rejette certaines
idées certains textes de l'église
par exemple l'ancien testament et la
résurrection de jésus
rien que ça ils sont excommuniés 2119
les juifs vivant en france par contre
sont très peu inquiété par l'inquisition
contrairement aux idées reçues ils ne
sont pas considérés comme hérétiques
qu'ils ont juste une autre religion faut
pas croire ils sont quand même parfois
persécutés voire même expulsé du pays et
par exemple à partir de 1969 qui doivent
porter un signe distinctif sur leurs
vêtements des accusations à leur
encontre prennent un nouvel essor à
partir du 12ème siècle on les accuse de
meurtres rituels chrétiens tout ça est
une autre histoire et comme je disais
les inquisiteurs s'intéresse très peu
elle au 12e siècle ce sont surtout des
autorités politiques de chaque pays qui
s'occupe des problèmes d'hérésie mais
pour le pape pas question de rater tout
le fun en 1198
il affirme que l'hérésie et un crime de
lèse majesté divine c'est un petit peu
grave non chaque paroisse il nomme un
commissionnaire un prêtre et quelques
laïcs chargeait de dénoncer les hérésies
et pour les juger il fait appel à des
hommes nouveaux issus des ordres
mendiants des moindres
petit à petit leur statut passe au
dessus de celui de l'évêque et sont
nommés directement par le pape
le premier se nomme etienne de saint
thibéry en 1234 il ya quelques règles
pour entrer dans l'acquisition
il faut avoir plus de 40 ans être un
homme bien sûr être intelligent honnête
pur demeure et s'y connaître en droit
théologique et canon certains
inquisiteur écrivent aussi de petit
manuel du parfait inquisiteur pour
épater leurs années
comment ça se passe concrètement
l'inquisiteur a en charge un vaste
territoire alors sa première action
quand ils arrivent quelque part et de se
présenter aux saignant locales afin de
s'assurer de son soutien et de lui
demander s'il prenait très pas déjà de 3
et rhétiques rhb ah oui le père mathieu
hérétiques de père en fils ensuite il
peut déjà jugé des hérétiques dont il a
connaissance ou bien effectuer une
grande tournée à travers le territoire
en faisant des discours dans les églises
et en invitant les hérétiques à venir se
présenter à lui directement
ne manquez pas la tournée du grand
inquisiteur à la tour sur orb 25 mai à b
rios de 27 et à méricourt le 29 entrée
gratuite dans l'église réduction sur les
peines de mort et d'emprisonnement si
vous venez vous confesser de vous même
en effet si des hérétiques vient de se
présenter à bille directement il ne
risque ni la peine de mort ni
l'emprisonnement mais plutôt
d'excommunion ou le bannissement but de
l'inquisiteur est d'aider les personnes
de les remettre dans le droit chemin et
pas de les enfoncer ses grandes tournées
se raréfient à partir du xiiie siècle et
sont remplacés par des poursuites
individuelles
on peut être amené à répondre devant
l'inquisiteur à partir de 14 ans pour
les garçons et douze ans pour les filles
ce qui correspond à l'âge légal pour se
marier chez nous pour qu'une personne
soit cité devant l'inquisiteur il faut
d'abord qu'elles soient dénoncés
anonymement de préférence pour éviter
les représailles
ensuite le curé lui fait savoir qu'elle
est convoqué par l'inquisiteur et l'anus
publiquement durant la messe pour bien
lui mettre la fiche
une fois qu'il comparaît il est
interrogé donc pour ça il doit d'abord
juré sur l'évangile
parce que le fait de ne pas jurer et
déjà un sacré indices les vaudois et les
cathares ou interdictions juré on va
commencer l'interrogatoire veillée jurés
lui refuse ok vous et hérétiques donc
non alors juré j'ai pas envie
ça commence bien le but de
l'interrogatoire et d'obtenir des aveux
pour ça ça passe par des questions mais
aussi éventuellement par le jeune ou la
privation de sommeil la torture n'est
pas autorisée au début elle n'est jamais
employé en premier recours
mais en l'autorisent progressivement à
partir du xiiie siècle surtout si on a
déjà de sérieux doutes sur la personne
certains inquisiteur continuent de la
troubler inefficace d'autres en abuse
en tout cas il en parle assez peu dans
leurs manuels les aveux données sur la
torture ne sont pas recevables donc ils
doivent être renouvelés 24 heures après
une fois l'interrogatoire terminé
l'hérétique peu ce soit à bure et ses
fautes dire qu'il ne se rendait pas
compte de ce qu'il faisait ou bien
persévérer dans cette croyance
dans le premier cas il peut être
condamné à effectuer un pèlerinage à la
prison ou alors à porter un signe
distinctif et s'il ne le porte pas ses
lunchs et l'inquisiteur ne prononce pas
les peines tout seul pour cela il réunit
un conseil et le jugement est prononcée
en public à l'église
par contre si les rhétiques refuse de
renoncer à ses croyances c'est la mort
mais l'inquisiteur ne peut pas prononcer
la peine de mort lui-même ce n'est pas
un juge
comment faire alors il le refile donc
aux autorités locales avec les
instructions qu'ils vont bien et on
organise un grand feu de joie en public
alors d'après les sources que j'ai lu on
empilait les fagots de bois jusqu'à sa
tête ce qui ne correspond pas trop à ce
qu'on voit dans les films mais je
trouvais ce détail amusant amusant
intéressant c'est aussi la famille du
condamné qui doit payer pour le bûcher
la peine de mort pour hérésie reste une
mesure exceptionnelle par rapport à
toutes les autres peines que j'ai cité
juste avant à partir des années 1330
l'hérésie se passe de mode et les
pauvres inquisiteur sont au bord du
chômage technique
comment relancer leurs activités en
surfant sur la vague de la mode
encore une fois en pénurie des rhétiques
découvrez les sorcières plus populaire
plus malfaisante plus facile à brûler
n'attendez plus et commandez vos
premières sorcières ont 36 15 sabah ou /
malus manificat rouen.fr autres malades
dans toute l'europe
l'idée qu'il existe des sorciers et
sorcières apparaît en même temps que se
développent l'image du diable en effet
le diable n'a pas toujours eu une grande
importance dans les croyances
chrétiennes mais à partir du xiiie
siècle on le voit partout dans les
légendes dans les illustrations et on
commence à se dire que ces petites
bonnes femmes qui font de la guérison à
partir de plantes ou qui font la
divination pourrait tenir leurs pouvoirs
du diable c'est de l'hérésie de nouveaux
hérétiques a brûlé oui parce que quand
il s'agit de sorcière ou de sorcier on
s'embête pas à les emprisonner imaginez
qu'ils pourraient influencer leurs
geôliers mais voulait brûler les
sorciers sont accusés d'avoir renié la
fois de maudire le baptême d'adorer le
diable de copuler avec lui de vous et à
son idole leur enfant et de lui
sacrifier ceux des autres de pratiquer
le cannibalisme de faire mourir les bons
et leur bétail et de faire courir les
fruits de la terre le procès des
sorcières ressemble à peu près à celui
des hérétiques
quelques détails près on a plus souvent
recours à la torture on pense aussi
qu'elle porte une marque que le diable
aurait fait sur leur corps afin
d'annuler leur baptême donc les
inquisiteurs cherche cette marque sur
leur corps partout on invente aussi le
supplice de l'eau qui est assez connu et
qui s'explique par le fait que comme on
pense qu'elles ont renié leur mattel on
pense qu'elles ne peuvent pas être
immergé et donc rien à voir avec le
poids du canard on les balance à l'eau
attaché un caillou et si elle coule
c'est qu'elles sont innocentes et dans
ce cas là on les remonte avec une corde
à laquelle elle était attachée n'est pas
des barbares bon si par un quelconque
hasard elle flotte par chance je
réaliserai un jour un autre épisode
entièrement consacré à la sorcellerie
on ne s'attardera pas sur la manière
dont se dérouler leur procès mais sur
les croyances de l'époque l'inquisition
pontifical est créée en 1231 et décline
dès les années 1970 avec le déclin des
hérésies les inquisiteurs se tourne
alors vers les sorcières mais ils ne
sont déjà plus aussi actif et
l'inquisition disparaît totalement au
xviiie siècle puisque les sorcières
succèdent aux hérétiques il est
intéressant de noter que les
vocabulaires se mélangent
par exemple je vous avais parlé des
vaudois qui était originaire de lyon est
bien à partir du 14e siècle le terme de
vaudry devient synonyme de sorcellerie
voilà j'espère que l'histoire de
l'inquisition vous intéresser et si vous
voulez en savoir plus sur le sujet je
vous conseille le livre de didier le fur
l'inquisition qui n'est pas très gros et
facile à lire et intéressant je vous
retrouve très prochainement pour un
épisode des créatrices du tube un peu en
lien avec le sujet
j'en dis pas plus en tout cas merci de
continuer à me regarder puisque j'ai vu
il n'ya pas longtemps qu'on était
maintenant 3000 voire plus sur ma chaîne
et ça fait plaisir
voilà continuer de partager mon travail
si ça vous plaît et à la prochaine
nains mat in the air est atone à obama
est ce un reato et autres avatars d'un
coup et oh well et eco art arrivé à la
ciao bella ciao bella ciao ciao ciao
érotico pourtant arrivé à kehl i cento
d'y mourir essaye au maillot des
radicaux au bella ciao bella ciao bella
ciao ciao ciao soyaux mouillot n'a guère
été co tous mis des vies c'est pire les
cp les rails lasours montagna où bella
ciao bella ciao bella ciao ciao charlie
cp lire est la suivante tania s'auto
l'ombre et diaw berciaud cause et les
gentils qui est passé à nous au bella
ciao bella ciao bella ciao ciao ciao
cosy regency que pas serrano c'est dire
ok belfiore équatoriale et de
l'hérétique au bella ciao bella ciao
bella ciao ciao ciao et quest for est
d'aérer tricot morteau perles la liberta